-Our next guest
is a talented actor you know
from shows like "The Punisher"
and "The Walking Dead."
He stars in "The Premise," which
debuts its first two episodes
on FX, on Hulu this Thursday,
and in
"The Many Saints of Newark,"
which is in theaters
and HBO Max October 1st.
He also produced and stars
in "Small Engine Repair,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, yes!
Oh, yes!
Who's my sexy man?
Do you like me
so, so [bleep] much?
God, did I miss this man.
You bought a new TV, huh?
-I did.
-Yeah, mine's, uh --
mine's bigger, but that's good.
-Please welcome to the show
Jon Bernthal.
How are you, Jon?
-What's going on, man?
Thank you for having me.
-Now, wait, is this --
This is a big deal for us.
I think this is the first time
this has happened.
Is that the same dog
we just saw from the clip?
-Oh, no! No, no.
-[ Laughs ]
-That is not.
No, that -- this is --
This is Bam Bam.
That was Boss.
Sadly, we -- that --
that was Boss's final movie.
Sadly, we --
we lost him after that one.
But, look,
we started talking about him,
he immediately left the --
left the couch.
But Bam Bam was in the movie.
He plays Boss in the flashbacks.
So, you know, we were --
we had all kinds.
Everybody's dogs
were in that movie.
Everybody who made the movie,
their kids were in the movie.
It was -- It was definitely
a labor of love.
-I like that Bam Bam left, like,
they had established
with our team, like,
"Do not ask about the dog."
[ Laughter ]
Like, that --
I almost wish your dog
had taken off a microphone
as it left.
-He le-- He left in anger.
He was like,
"Do not talk about me.
I did not sign up for this."
-So, this is really cool,
because this is a play
you did I guess
about a decade ago.
It takes place in New Hampshire,
where I'm from.
I know you're not
from New Hampshire,
but you have spent
some time there.
-I love New Hampshire.
I -- I -- you know,
New Hampshire is --
some of my greatest memories
are -- are from New Hampshire.
I love the state.
I love everything
the state stands for.
I worked there in -- at a summer
camp when I was younger.
And then, just this year,
I dropped my two little boys off
at that same summer camp,
which, I have to tell you --
I mean, they're 8 and 9.
They're pretty young.
And so to say goodbye to them
for a month
was definitely very difficult.
But, you know, I --
They loved it.
They loved being there.
You know,
my boys are very different.
My 9-year-old, Henry, he --
it was rough for him.
You know, he -- he had --
You could just see sort of
the tears bubbling up
in his eyes.
And, you know, I was --
was being a dad, you know,
and I gave him a big hug,
and he said,
"Dad, I think I'm gonna cry."
And I said, "Man,
just go ahead, let it out.
I'm right here."
And we kind of touched noses.
And he said, "No, Dad,
I'm gonna be strong for you."
And he turned around
and walked away.
And as that happened,
my other son, Bill,
just smacked me in the ass
and he said,
"See you around, fat man,"
and just walked off
in the other direction.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, they're --
they're very different.
But I think New Hampshire
was just as good for them
as it was for me.
-That's fantastic.
This is --
You know, obviously,
a movie set
is a very controlled atmosphere.
But this
is a really intense story,
which I imagine, on stage,
there were less sort of
safety guardrails
when you were going through
performing a piece like this.
-Look, the --
the play started in --
in sort of as humble a beginning
as possible.
It was in this teeny little
40-seat theater.
It was a 10:30-at-night play.
You know, what was really
wonderful about it, man,
is that a lot of my friends
came who are cops, firemen,
pro fighters,
guys who don't really
come to the theater very often.
And they were mixing with this,
you know,
super progressive
L.A. theater scene.
And what we found was sort of
this explosive, kind of --
really just -- just beautiful --
Everyone just really dug it.
Every--
It -- It was.
It was dangerous.
It was exciting.
It made you think.
And I think the trick was,
"How do you capture that
in a film?"
And I really do --
I really do think that,
you know, what's very special
about this is,
you know, this film, it will --
you know,
it's gonna make you laugh.
You know, there --
there are times where it will
definitely make you cry.
It might offend
the heck out of you.
But it -- it --
more than anything else,
I think it will
really make you think.
And I think we captured
what was special about the play
and got it into the film.
-You have an incredibly
unique -- it strikes me,
at least -- journey,
insofar as where you got
your acting training.
You did it in the States,
but you also found
your way to Russia.
Who told you it would be a good
idea to -- to go train there
and, in the end, did it end up
being a good call?
-Look, I'm very grateful for --
for -- for my time in Russia.
I went there, I played a --
I played a little bit of
pro baseball over there,
and that's where I really
studied acting.
And I think I would not
be doing what I'm doing now
if it wasn't for that.
I'm enormously grateful,
you know, to be doing this.
And it was a teacher.
I think you can't undervalue
or underestimate
the power that a teacher has.
My teacher -- my first acting
teacher was Alma Becker.
She's the woman who ended up
marrying my wife and I.
She sent me to Russia.
She -- She knew --
I think probably to get away
from my maniac friends
would probably be a good thing
to get as far away as possible.
Maybe that had something
to do with it.
But I think the theater training
in Russia, you know,
it's extremely disciplined.
And, you know,
I'm a -- I'm a boxer.
I played college sports.
I played football.
I played baseball.
There is nothing that came close
to the discipline and the rigor
of the Russian theater.
And, you know, I'm --
I'm very grateful that I kind of
learned this thing over there
rather than here.
-You also -- I've read that
when you first started acting,
your goal was just to be
an extra in "The Sopranos."
And there's nothing I'm looking
forward to more than
"The Many Saints of Newark,"
which is the "Sopranos" film
that's coming out,
that David Chase has obviously
been kind enough
to give to the world.
How exciting was it to --
to get to enter that universe?
-Look, you know, a blessing.
You know,
super humbling and exciting.
Yeah.
I mean, all I wanted was
just an audition to --
to try to get onto that set.
That's when I was sort of,
you know,
starting out as an actor.
And, look, I can't tell you how
honored I am to be a part of it.
I think what Michael Gandolfini,
you know, does in this movie
and to sort of be a part
of his journey
and stepping into, you know,
his father's shoes,
I just feel really honored
that I get to, you know,
walk alongside him.
And I think he approached it
with courage,
and he approached it with,
you know, real dedication.
And, you know, my job there
was to sort of stand by him,
and I believe in this young man,
and I think he's going to --
I think people are gonna
really enjoy what he does.
-Also, I've heard, you know,
there are certain things
where even I can't
get an early copy of it.
-Oh, no.
-I'm trying.
Can't get it.
But I've heard
it's really [bleep] good.
Is it good?
-Man, look, to --
to be honest with you,
I haven't seen it myself.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel better now.
I feel better now.
-What I will say is that,
you know, look, it's different.
I think people that are gonna
go in and expecting
"The Sopranos," it's not that.
I think that it was very smart
that they set it in the past
and that it's a genuine prequel.
What you will see as being
a real sort of "Sopranos" fan
is that, I think that, you know,
David Chase has this sort of
encyclopedic kind of
Shakespearean knowledge
of these characters.
And you will see things --
you will see that when he was
writing this show, you know,
during its heyday,
he clearly understood
the full history of who
these characters were.
And I think
that's just kind of --
You know, the real super fans,
I think it's just gonna be
so much fun.
And I think the performances,
you know,
Vera did and Corey
and Alessandro --
I mean, the performances
are gonna be great.
I know that, 'cause I saw
what they were doing.
But, yeah, they haven't
showed it to me, either, yet.
-All right, well,
thank you very much
for making me feel better
about myself.
Congratulations on everything,
and thanks so much
for making the time for us.
-I appreciate it, man.
Thank you for having me.
-"Small Engine Repair"
is in theaters now.